البدايه اذا من تطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث قال الكريم لن ان محاولات
التفاوض مع واشنطن والنيتو باءت بالفشل
وشدد على مواصله موسكو وعمليتها العسكريه
في اوكرانيا وذلك بعد يوم من مطالبه بيض
روسيا بسحب قوتها قبل اي حوار وهي الدعوه
التي كررها المستشار الالماني في اتصال
هاتفي مع بوتين اليوم للمتابعه ينضم الينا
من موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره زور شوج ومن
برلين مراسل الجزيره عيسى طيب وابدا معك
زوار مما قاله
عن كلام بوتين في اتصال طبعا مع المستشار
الالماني فيما يتعلق بفشل محاوله التفاوض
[تصفيق]
مساء الخير عبد القادر الكريمنج اجابا
بشكل مقتضى واضح وصريح على
مقترح بايدين امس انه مستحيل مستحيل ان
تسحب روسيا قواتها من اوكرانيا وانها
تواصل عمليتها العسكريه وهناك حتى تحقيق
اهدافها المتحدث باسم الكربلاند بيتريب
سكوف قال بشكل مباشر ان هناك معطيات جديده
هي التي يمكن ان تكون
اساسا وثوابك لاي تفاوض مع الغرو ومع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي ان هناك
اراضي جديده تم ضمها الى روسيا وعدم
اعتراف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على حد
التعبيره باراضي روسيا الجديده ويشكل
عائقا كبيرا امام اي مفاوضات مع الجانب
الاميركي ذكر بسكوف همم تلك المفاوضات
التي بدات بالفشل والتي كانت بين روسيا
وهمم حلف الناته والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومنظمه معاهده ومنظمه الامنه
والتعاون في اوروبا التي التي انطلقت في
ديسمبر من العام الماضي واستمرت مع مطلع
العام الجاري قبل الحرب الروسي على
اوكرانيا والتي تطهورت حول ضمانات امنيه
قدمتها روسيا لتجديد برايها العالم هذه
المواجهه التي تجري الان بين اخطابه ولكنه
همم الغرب الجمعي كما قال بسكوف رفض كل
المقترحات همم الروسيه من الواضح ان روسيا
متماسكه همم بقراراتها وبخياراتها حتى اخر
لحظه وهذا ما كتبته ايضا من خلال اتصال
تمام بين الرئيس الروسي في وادي ميرفتر ان
شاء الله المانيا
للرئيس المستشار الالماني ان همم على
المانيا ان تعيدها النظر في رؤيتها وفي
حساباتها في ما يتعلق بها الحرب في
اوكرانيا وان هناك تهديد مباشره لروسيا
وانا استمرار الغرب بدعم اوكراني عسكريا
وماليا
واقتصاديا لن يساهم باي شكل من الاشكال في
انهاء في هذا
البلد لماذا عما نقلته والمستشاريه من
الاتصال بين الرئيس الروسي والمستشار
الالماني
نعم الروايه الالمانيه للمحدث الهاتفيه
بين المستشار الالماني والاشوتس والرئيس
الروسي في راديو بوتين كان تقول بان
المستشار الذي تحدث لمده ساعه كامله مع
الرئيس الروسي اذن فيه مباشره الضربات
التي يقودها الرئيس الروسي لانه الشوط
الثاني من يستعمل عباره ان هذه الحرب هي
حرب الرئيس دانا مباشره للرئيس الروسي
الضربات التي يقوم بها وتقوم بها موسكو في
على البنيه التحتيه المدنيه في اوكرانيا
ايضا قلال بيان بان الشورتز اكدال لبوتين
بان المانيا الماضيه في دعمها لاوكرانيا
للدفاع عن نفسه وبانها لم تتراجع عن هذا
المبدا وهو في الاشاره الى مطالب
بان البيان كان يطالب همم المانيا
الاخر الذي قال عنه البيان بان الشؤون
صرافه من سقف التحدي
عندما قال بان هذه مبعث هي التي تم وصل
نحن هي انتهاك مباشر للقانون الدولي وايضا
على موسكو ان تسحب جنودها فورا وفي اقرب
وقت وان تلجا الى الحل الدبلوماسي بعيدا
عن المراوغه ايضا تحدث المستشار الالماني
في في البيان الذي اعلنته الحكومه
الالمانيه بانه اكد مع نظيره مع مع الرئيس
الروسي مساله التفاؤكم ازمه الغذاء وهي
احدى كما قال البيان افرازات الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا لكنهما في اتفقنا
بحسب البيان بان يلقيها على خطوط الاتصال
بينهما وهذا المبدا دائما تعرف بها
المانيا في علاقتها بان همم الحفاظ على
الحد الادنى من الاتصال والتشاور المباشر
بين الزعيمين هو هذا اليه مهمه
الحرب وتداعياتها وايضا ذهابها بعيدا
الامر الاخر في نهايه البيان تحدث عن
مساله الحبوب وبانهم ركز على مساله اهميه
مواصلات الاتفاقيه التي ترعاها الامم
المتحده لاخراج الحبوب الاوكرانيه للعالم
ثم ايضا لا ننسى لان اليوم الاثنين القادم
تعتزم المانيا مع شركائها الغربيه على
الذهاب بحسب مصادر هنا تتحدث برلين على
الذهاب الى اتفاقيه تثقيف اسعار الطاقه
الروسيه وخصوصا الطاقه القادمه عن طريق
البحار وحظرها وبالتالي هو تصعيد جديد
تقوم به برلين اتجاه موسكو واتجاه هذه
الحرب نعم عسى طيبه وشكرا جزيلا لكما